bilan moyen pour la sûreté nucléaire en
ile-de-france selon l'asn
si la région ne dispose pas de centrales
sur son territoire de nombreuses
installations sont en revanche présentes
pour la médecine le traitement des
déchets nucléaires ou encore la
recherche d'ailleurs l'asn pointent du
doigt dans son bilan 2016 l'une des
installations situées dans l'essonne le
cis bio une usine qui produit des
médicaments radiopharmaceutiques et qui
présentent des défauts d'exploitation
depuis plusieurs années c'est des
défauts des défauts trigger finalement
défaut d'application des procédures qui
manifestent lé dé sans doute un les
défaillances d'organisation des
défaillances dans la manière dont
l'exploitant était organisée pour
conduire sur l'installation
mauvais point aussi pour les
installations basées à
fontenay-aux-roses l'asn ne considère
pas le niveau de sûreté pleinement
satisfaisant sur place bilan favorable
en revanche pour le cea de saclay et
l'ensemble du nucléaire de proximité qui
concerne essentiellement le secteur
médical même si l'utilisation des
appareils radiologique peut être aussi
améliorée et des travailleurs qui ne se
protègent pas suffisamment ne sont pas
assez formés et utilisent à mauvais
escient parfois leurs appareils ne
sachant pas les régler pour optimiser
vraiment le compromis entre une
irradiation minimale et une qualité
d'image suffisante pour réaliser le
geste en 2016 l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire a effectué plus de 220
inspections sur site en ile de france
une quarantaine d'incidents mineurs lui
ont été signalés